Щоб відбулась ця зустріч
між Петром Порошенком і Дональдом Трампом
у червні минулого року
начебто було заплачено
від 400 до 600 тисяч доларів
Як повідомляє Бі-бі-сі з посиланням
на власні джерела
ці гроші отримав адвокатТрампа
МайклКоен від посередників
які діяли в інтересах Петра Порошенка
При цьому адвокат Трампа
не був офіційним лобістом
як того вимагає американське законодавство
Офіційний Київ заперечує
що ця зустріч була проплаченою
і вважає матеріал Бі-бі-сі дезінформацією і фейком
щоб нашкодити українсько-американським відносинам
Опитані DW експерти так не вважають
Україна зробила багато інших кроків, наприклад, купівля пенсільванського вугілля
придбання ядерного палива від компанії Westinghouse
надання мільярдного контракту General Electric
на модернізацію локомотивів
щоб налагодити відносини
з новою адміністрацією США
Тож я думаю, що ця справа більше зачепить не Порошенка
чи українсько-американські відносини
а Трампа і розслідування щодо нього
Спецпрокурор Роберт Мюллер
розслідує справу щодо можливого втручання
Росії
у президентські вибори в США,
на яких переміг Дональд Трамп
і щодо можливих його зв’язків з Кремлем
Як повідомляє видання The Washington Post
адвокат Трампа Майкл Коен відіграв центральну роль
у двох епізодах розслідування
зокрема, у переговорах про будівництво
Trump Tower у Москві
Через тиск на Коена прокурори прагнуть
отримати свідчення проти Трампа,
вважають експерти
Минулого місяця агенти ФБР обшукали офіс
адвоката Трампа через підозри у шахрайстві
Дональд Трамп назвав це "полюванням на відьом"
і "ганьбою"
На відміну від адміністрації Порошенка
яка називає матеріал Бі-бі-сі "персональною атакою на президентів України і США"
в журналістських колах автор статті Пол Вуд
має незаплямовану репутацію
Високоповажний журналіст Бі-бі-сі
Вуд не є найманим чи упередженим репортером
також зазначає, що антикорупційне розслідування,
яке проводила Україна
щодо колишнього керівника передвиборної кампанії Трампа Пола Манафорта
завершилося незабаром після того,
як Трамп зустрівся з Порошенком
Ви можете бути певними
що спецпрокурор Роберт Мюллер перевірить
чи було це просто збігом обставин
На думку експертів, на Київ
зараз чинитиметься тиск
з боку американських політиків-демократів
На початку цього місяця троє сенаторів-демократів
вже звернулися з відкритим листом і запитаннями
до генпрокурора України Юрія Луценка
з проханням роз'яснити інформацію видання The New York Times
про начебто блокування Україною
розслідування щодо Манафорта
Журналісти проводять паралелі
з постачанням в Україну
американського протитанковогоозброєння Javelin
із замороженням розслідування справ,
пов'язаних із колишнім керівником
передвиборної кампанії Трампа